oh there do they call to me where do
they go
[Music]
like so many popular franchises that
have reinvented themselves in recent
years the new god of war dips into the
well of open-world RPG tropes it also
shifts its focus to Norse mythology
casting off the iconic Greek gods and
legends that provided the basis for
every previous game I dare say it's
about time these major shifts don't
signal the end of God of War as we know
it instead they allow the series DNA to
express itself in new ways Santa Monica
studio has converted a furious
bloodthirsty icon and Kratos into an
emotionally complex father figure
part of him retains the old violent
tendencies that made him a star so long
ago but now with his young son at Reyes
to protect and guide we also see Kratos
take a deep breath and bury his savage
instincts in order to set a positive
example now it God is up only fire only
fire when I tell you to fire I'm sorry
do not be sorry be better thanks to the
natural writing fitting voice actors and
flawless animation it's easy to get
sucked into the duo's journey and buy
into their mutual growth though he is a
teacher
Kratos carries a mountain of grief and
self-pity that only the innocence of his
son can help him overcome and at Reyes
experiences his own ups and downs that
might have set him down a very different
path if not for Kratos his guiding hand
yeah weak again it's the death of his
mother prior to the start of the game
that thrusts at Reyes and Kratos outward
from their sanctuary in the woods her
dying wish was to have her ashes spread
atop the highest peak in the land as if
wild predators and ghastly fiends
weren't obstacles enough representatives
from the pantheon of Norse mythology
arise in an attempt to disrupt their
mission establishing the amplified
stakes and The Clash of impressive
mythical forces that you expect from God
of War
[Applause]
and like its predecessors God of War is
a technical and artistic showcase it is
without a doubt one of the best-looking
console games ever released with every
breathtaking environment and mythical
character exhibiting impressive
attention to detail and beautifying
flourishes aplenty the vision behind all
this is evident in criticism 'it ikkyu
lessly grizzled physique and his
weathered equipment in the atmospheric
effects that transform believably rustic
environments into the stuff of dreams
and in the overall design and structure
of the world itself the majority of your
journey is set any large realm of
Midgard at its heart lies a huge lake
that you can explore by canoe at your
leisure with a coastline dotted by
optional puzzles formidable opponents
and entrances to the map's primary
regions your mission will carry you
through to most of these places and
along the way you'll likely take note of
inaccessible pathways and glimpses of
locked away treasure
there's always ample room to explore off
the main path and good reasons to give
in to curiosity regardless but these
teases in particular spur you to
re-examine previously visited areas as
your capabilities expand with the boy
fighting by your side firing arrows or
choking unsuspecting enemies you will
team up against corrupted cave trolls
face towering beasts and fight hundreds
of intelligent supernatural warriors
Kratos prefers to use an axe these days
which functions very differently than
the chained blades of chaos he's known
for this comes with a very satisfying
and cool ability to magically summon
your weapon to your hand a bit like Thor
and his hammer it's a move that never
gets old and really neither does combat
in general the new over-the-shoulder
camera brings you directly into the fray
and consequently limits your view you
have to be ready to avoid attacks or
turn around and block at a moment's
notice when facing a group of enemies
it's rare that you can actually spam
combos without putting yourself at risk
and this emphasis on mindfulness
solidifies god of War's graduation from
the traditional hack and slash doldrums
the basic set of close-range combos and
weapon behaviors can be expanded by
pouring experience points into skill
trees and by activating magical rune
abilities that bind your to attack
inputs there are a lot of options to
consider in tactics to learn including
skill trees for fighting empty handed
there's a wonderful rhythm to be found
when switching from your axe to your
fists and then into Kratos is satisfying
brutal execution moves all the while
ducking and rolling out of harm's way
you can absolutely stumble into
incredibly punishing enemies that are
made easier with the mastery of every
available skill but you can also succeed
at any level with the deft timing alone
at Reyes can't be configured to the same
extent that Kratos can but there are
still a lot of ways to tailor these
capabilities to your liking thanks to
the smart button layout it's actually
very easy to both attack and defend as
Kratos while also commanding at Reyes to
focus his bow on targets in specific
ways you aren't juggling as many actions
as you might in a game like horizon zero
dawn but God of War still gives you
plenty to do in any given moment it
makes you feel like an experienced
warrior in the process character
customization also extends to the armor
that Kratos Senate Reyes wear which can
influence a range of character stats
elemental affinities and may also
include slots for enchantments that
grant further bonuses armor can be
purchased or crafted using the few
resources scattered around the world and
can be upgraded by the games too
blacksmiths to dwarven brothers
constantly at odds with each other
there's Brock the foul-mouthed blue
dwarf war you want a hug and sindri a
far more gentle yet tragically
germaphobic fellow a gag that is usually
funny though occasionally pushed a bit
too hard that handle is no filthy as
enjoyable as these two can be it's
Mamere that ultimately steals the show
take these two what floss wank cows and
the horned one-eyed sage accompanies
unit Reyes for the majority of the game
serving as your guide to Midgard and an
inside source into the ins and outs of
Norse politics god of wars cast is
convincing and oddly and chanting at
times but the real accomplishment is how
even though there are just a handful of
characters to interact with they're
tantalizing anecdotes draw you into the
world and imbue the land with a tangible
of history if there's any piece of the
overarching mission that feels like a
letdown it's the final battle against
the primary antagonist
he's great from a narrative standpoint
unraveling in a manner that changes your
perspective but it's the fight itself
that leaves you wanting there are plenty
of big boss battles and tests of skill
throughout the course of the game yet
this fight doesn't reach the same
heights and feels like it was played a
little bit safe it could be an effective
configuring kratos anyt Reyes just sew
or it may just be too easy to begin with
thankfully there are hints of more
difficult battles to come and odds are
you'll be so hooked by the story's
pacing and procession of events that
there will be plenty of side activities
left after the credits roll god of war
isn't set in a massive open world but it
is stuffed with secrets and quests where
most games with long and diverse quest
opportunities tend to run a bit stale by
the end god of war has the opposite
effect it's far longer than it needs to
be though you hope you never run out of
things to do in many ways God of War is
what the series has always been it's a
spectacular action game with epic set
pieces big-budget production values and
hard-hitting combat that grows more
feverish and impressive as you progress
what may surprise you is how mature
storytelling has become like Kratos god
of war recalls the past while
acknowledging the need to improve
everything new it does is for the better
and everything it holds on to benefits
as a result Kratos is no longer a
predictable brew God of War is no longer
an old-fashioned action series with this
reboot it confidently walks on new paths
that will hopefully lead to more
exciting adventures to come
[Applause]
you